how many alien civilizations do you
think are out there there's there's
there's like trillions of environments
aka planets
uh or
maybe you can think even bigger than
planets
how many
life-like organisms do you think are uh
out there thriving and maybe how many do
you think are long gone but we're once
here
i think well
innumerable uh
i think in terms of the weight of zero
much greater than zero i mean i would
just be surprised what a waste right of
all that space just for us if we're
never going to get there
um
that would be my first
way to think about it
but
second i mean
i remember when i was about seven or
eight years old and i would love if any
of your listeners could find this
national geographic i remember opening
uh the page of the national league
graphic i was about again seven to ten
years old
and it was sort of a current picture of
the universe it was around probably 1968
i remember looking at it and thinking
what kinds of
empires have risen and fallen across
that space
that we'll never know about and would
isn't that sad that we know nothing
about something so grand
uh and so i've always been a reader of
science fiction because i like
the creative ideas of what people come
up with and i especially like science
fiction writers that base it in good
science but base it also in evolution
that if you evolve a civilization
from something
lifelike right some sort of biology
its assumptions about the universe will
come from
the environment in which it grew up so
for instance larry niven is a great
writer uh and he imagines different
kinds of
civilizations in some cases what happens
if
uh evolut what happens if intelligence
evolved from a herd animal
right would you lead from behind
right would you be
uh you know in his case one of them were
the so-called puppeteers
and to them the moral imperative is
cowardice
you put other people forward to run the
risk for you
right and so he writes entire books
around that premise
there's another guy uh bryn david brin
is his name and he writes the so-called
um
uplift universe books and in those he
takes different
uh
intelligences
each from a different evolutionary
background
and then he posits
a civilization based around
where and what they came from
and so
to me i mean that's that's just fun but
i mean back to your original question
is
how many are there i think as as as many
stars as we can see
now how many are currently there
i don't know i mean that's the whole
that's the whole question of you know
how long can a civilization last before
it
runs out of steam and you
for instance does it just get bored or
does it transcend to something else or
does it say i've seen enough and i'm
done what does running out of steam look
like it could be destroy itself or get
bored you know i said or we've we've
done everything we can and
they just decide to stop i don't know
i just don't know it's the elon musk
worry that we stop reproducing or we
slow down the reproduction rate to where
uh the population can go to zero can go
to zero and and we can't and we collapse
i mean so the only way to
get around that is uh perhaps
create enough machines with ai to take
care of us
[Laughter]
what could possibly go wrong
you